zunächst einmal es war richtig dass die
bundesregierung den russischen
botschafter einbestellt hat aus meiner
sicht hätte das auch früher stattfinden
können nun ist das erfolgt und aus
meiner sicht ist der sachverhalt
zunächst einmal klar es ist eindeutig
die russische handschrift erkennbar wir
reden hier von einem chemischen
kampfstoff das ist nicht etwas was man
einfach so eben in einem keller
herstellen kann sondern da dafür
benötigt man staatliche strukturen
dementsprechend ist die anschrift und
die methodik russlands erkennbar
und deutschland ist aufgefordert
gemeinsam mit anderen europäischen
staaten hier eine gemeinsame linie zu
finden das ist notwendig an der stelle
und man muss ganz konkret auch über
sanktionen sprechen und man wird in den
nächsten tagen den fall weiter aufklären
das heißt noch mehr über den hintergrund
über die verbindung über die person
erfahren können möglicherweise wenn die
aufklärung gelingt und hier muss man
auch sehr konkret über personenbezogene
sanktionen gegen personen die damit
verbunden waren die zumindest involviert
waren auch hier sehr konkret auch damit
dann auch aktiv er also sie sprechen von
aufklärungen sie sprechen von sanktionen
man muss ja davon ausgehen dass russland
da jetzt kein großes interesse hat das
ganze aufzuklären und sanktionen helfen
jetzt auch nicht immer unbedingt wie
kann man denn irgendwie konkrete druck
auf russland ausüben und sagen stopp bis
hierhin und nicht weiter
naja ich bin zunächst aber davon
überzeugt dass russland alles tun wird
damit aufklärung nicht möglich sein wird
das ist aus meiner sicht völlig klar und
wir kennen auch diese methodik man wird
das alles von einem von der russischen
seite aus man wird wieder negative
finden die richtung
verschwörungstheorien gehen wir kennen
das alles nur wenn man nicht reagiert
dann sind das definitiv falsche signale
die man an russland ist sendet und das
wäre ja auch nicht richtig schauen sie
mal es ist ja nicht ist es ja nicht nur
dieser fall wenn wir auch die russische
politik insgesamt der letzten jahre
betrachten sei es die russische
außenpolitik leisten als die russische
innenpolitik der umgang mit
oppositionellen im eigenen land das sind
alles dinge die können wir so nicht
ignorieren und ich wunder mich
wieder über die stimmen die auch in
deutschland existieren sowohl in der
politik als auch bei journalisten die
mir erzählen sollten mehr erzählen oder
uns erzählen wir müssen auf russland zu
gehen und sanktion abbauen
man sieht wie falsch diese analyse ist
mit dem heutigen russland sind vertraute
vertrauensvolle zusammenarbeit oder
kooperation nicht möglich hier
funktioniert nur eine deutliche und eine
klare kante das heißt eine klare
europäische antwort auf die russische
politik und auch die russische art und
weise wie politik gemacht wird
sie sprechen uns jetzt gerade an sie
sind für eine klare kante die
bundesregierung ist daher ein bisschen
zögerlich
sie sagen es auch wir kennen das alles
also russland vertuscht dass wir wissen
verschwörungstheorien was die uns alles
weismachen wollen
was sagt denn dass über das verhältnis
russland deutschland beziehungsweise
sehen was mal ein bisschen größer
russland europa aus es fehlt es in
deutschland und europa das feld dass
russland und deutschland und russland um
europa ist in einem schrecklichen
zustand das muss man an der stelle sagen
selbstverständlich gibt es sicherheit in
europa nur mit russland aber die art und
weise wie gerade von der russischen
seite politik gemacht wird das ist nicht
etwas was hingenommen wird ja wir reden
heute über diesen fall morgen reden wir
über die russische rolle im syriens
übermorgen reden wir über die russische
rolle in der ukraine oder in libyen
danach reden wir wieder über
cyberattacken wir haben demnächst einen
bundestagswahl vor der haustür ich bin
offen davon überzeugt dass russland
versucht alles tun wird um diese
bundestagswahl auch nicht zu stören
also das heißt wir haben es hier mit
einem akteur zu tun der nicht zimperlich
ist und vor allem alles tut und den
westen oder zumindest in europa
verstimmung zu hinterlassen und das ist
etwas was wir nicht so hinnehmen können
das heißt ich warne davor zu glauben
dass man hier romantisch über russland
denken soll
nein hier sind knallharte interessen die
vom system putin formuliert werden und
die darf man sich in europa nicht
gefallen lassen würde man als europäer
schweigen wird man nichts sagen wird man
alles ignorieren dann würde man das
nicht als dialog
sondern man würde das eindeutig von der
form system putin als schwäche der
europäer wahrnehmen oder analysieren und
insgesamt haben wir sowieso das problem
dass russland die europäer derzeit als
sehr schwach und nicht handlungsfähig
betreibe